the show opens in the year 1947 where
father mcmurty is seen giving a sermon
at a church after completing the session
he bids goodbye to one of his
parishioners and walks back to his
quarters unbeknownst to him a young man
Edmund tollisen is keeping a close eye
on him upon arrival father mcmurty joins
his friends for dinner while eating the
other priests plan on going for a movie
but father mcmurdy faints illness and
decides to stay home after the meal he
heads to his room locks the door and
takes out a lingerie magazine to gratify
himself at least the people in that
magazine are of age however his private
time is soon interrupted by a doorbell
the father goes to answer the door and
finds Edmund who pretends that his car
broke down unaware of his actual
intentions father mcmurty invites him
inside offering coffee later on the
other priests Andrews Coleman admy and
mol Sullivan return home from the show
and retire to their respective rooms
adamy heads into the bathroom room only
to be greeted by a grim sight the
lifeless body of father mcmurty in the
tub with his throat slit just then
Edmund appears from behind and bashes
adm's face into the toilet seat
repeatedly until until he dies the
commotion alerts the other priests and
they come out to check however they also
succumb to the same fate at last Edmund
comes face to face with the old monor
before attacking him the Young Man
reveals that he's the son of Margaret
Maguire she is the same woman who was
assaulted by the priests forcing her
into prostitution Edmond then stabs
monor with a kitchen knife while
asserting that someone killed his mother
in the Brothel House making him an
orphan unbeknownst to him father Andrews
Witnesses the horror from under the bed
desperately trying to keep quiet the
scene then cuts to 6 months later
showing our protagonist Mildred ratchet
she is sitting inside her car in a gas
station watching young people sharing a
passionate kiss shortly after an
attendant hands her a map T Lucia and
the newspaper detailing The Vicious
priest Massacre upon going through the
news she learns that the killer will
soon be sent to luia state hospital for
psychiatric evaluation following this
Mildred heads to Lucia California a
small City with only 985 inhabitants
after a long drive she arrives at an
Oceanside motel and checks into her room
she then talks with the owner and learns
that several reporters are flocking into
the city because there's a
$5,000 reward for anyone who gets the
first shot of the clergy killer just
before she enters her room Mildred
catches the eye of a neighbor Charles
way wght but the owner makes it clear
that she isn't allowed to share her room
with any guys no making me jealous it's
against the rules the next day mildre
drives to Lucius state hospital and
meets the head nurse Betsy bucket she
introduces herself as a new night shift
nurse and shows her a job interview
letter claiming that she has an
appointment with the head of the
hospital Dr Richard Hanover but neither
Betsy nor Richard seem to have any prior
knowledge of this Betsy then asks her to
come back some other time because the
doctor hasn't arrived yet however
Mildred decides to wait as she has no
other work to do sometime later she goes
to the bathroom where she hears a
distant scream and clattering she
follows the noise to the adjacent room
and finds a nurse Amelia engaged in
Intimate activity with an orderly nurse
hand me the stethoscope stat meanwhile
Richard is seen waiting for his
appointment with Governor George Wilburn
but the meeting is once again postponed
turns out that Richard has been visiting
the governor's office every month in
order to pitch for funding of this
hospital but the uninterested George
refuses to meet him every time when
Richard returns back to the hospital he
is informed about Mildred the doctor has
no recollection of such an appointment
but Mildred masterfully manipulates the
conversation in such a way that he
forgets the topic of the interview she
reveals that she was a nurse in the
Pacific Theater during the war and that
she aims to cure as many people as she
can on although he admires her passion
Richard doesn't have enough resources to
bring her on nor are there any openings
on her way out Mildred steals Amelia's
purse and learns her home address it
seems she likes getting screwed and
Ratchet is happy to oblige in the next
scene she goes to Amelia's house where
she finds her husband and daughter
heading out she pretends to be her
school friend who has come here to meet
her but since Amelia isn't home her
husband agrees to tell her about the
visit Mildred then heads to her Motel
where she crosses paths with Charles and
invites him to her room as they come
closer she feels uncomfortable and
suggests that they sit and talk for a
while however the guy doesn't seem to be
interested in this so he leaves that
evening Mildred meets with Amelia at a
bar and blackmails her into giving up
her nursing position she claims that she
desperately wants a job at the hospital
and since there aren't any openings she
is forced to create one and if Amelia
doesn't comply she'll expose her secret
affair to her husband on the other hand
Richard receives an unexpected visit
from from Georgia's Secretary gwendolin
who proposes making his Hospital the
centerpiece of the governor's reelection
campaign with the success of Lucia state
hospital they can force the public to
see the governor as a leader upon
realizing that it's beneficial for the
hospital Richard agrees to the proposal
in the aftermath he instructs Betsy to
arrange a patient to staff ratio of 10
to1 but they seem to be short on staff
so Richard remembers Mildred and hires
her immediately with the governor
finally willing to back Richard the
press surrounds the hospital as a result
Betsy instructs the staff to perform
their Duty in the utmost professional
manner as possible later that day the
governor visits the hospital and Richard
gives him a tour in the meantime Mildred
prepares the daily medicine cart for
their patients during which she grabs a
blood pressure reducer and slips it into
one of the patients medication this
causes the patient to collapse which
catches everyone's attention including
the governor she then takes the
Spotlight by saving the patient's life
which makes her a star in in the eyes of
the press and the governor afterward
meld chats with one of the patients
named Dario Salvatore and tries to
manipulate him into committing the
unthinkable she bonds with him over a
common topic of losing a brother and
eventually reveals a harsh truth he'll
never get out of the hospital because
his family doesn't want to see him again
she further asserts that he deserves to
be free from all the pain and then
guides him to Richard's office showing
him a letter opener Dario uses this tool
to slit his own throat which kills him
on the spot all of this seems to be a
big Ploy by Mildred to work her way up
the ladder while the governor addresses
the Press Richard returns to his office
room and is horrified to witness the
brutal death of Dario he panics thinking
about the consequences if the Press
finds this out at the same time Mildred
approaches him and assures that she'll
take care of the body pretending to be a
great helper Richard then joins the
governor in the press conference while
Mildred cleans up the room and disposes
of the body in the incinerator the same
night Edmund is brought to the hospital
to determine if he's well enough to
stand trial he is taken to a secure
Cellar beneath the hospital and locked
there seizing the right moment Mildred
sneaks into the basement to meet him
tears run down their faces as they see
each other indicating that they share
some kind of bond Edmond tells her that
he doesn't want to die to which she
promises that she will save him
following the mass media coverage of
Governor wilburn's support of Lucius
State Hospital Richard introduces his
breakthrough treatment the frontal
labotomy as a result hundreds of people
Afflicted with different mental
illnesses admit themselves to the
hospital among the patients are Len
bronley a former theater actor with
memory loss Lily cartrite experiencing
struggles related to her sexual
orientation Peter a young man troubled
by Daydreams and ingred Blicks a
renowned European opera singer grappling
with Melancholia Richard who is
confident in his treatment invites
Randall Bergland The Head of the State
detentions Bureau Annie Hard Castle an
administrative assistant to the director
of state finance and gwendolin and who
the hell cares about what gwendaline is
or does to observe the treatment process
shortly after the patients are brought
to the operating theater and are mildly
sedated before undergoing the labotomy
procedure the process proves to be too
gruesome which is evident by the fact
that Annie faints as Richard drills into
the patient's skulls later that day
Mildred visits father Andrews the only
survivor of the clergy kill attack she
tries to convince him that she's on his
side and that she wants to cleanse the
world of evil like Edmund for this she
urges him to describe what he saw to
Richard Andrews is reluctant to speak on
the matter as he seems to have had a
nervous breakdown following the attack
however Mildred emphasizes the necessity
in doing so because Edmund will commit
more crimes if he's released the
conversation breaks the father into
tears clearly showing that he's weak
back at Lucia Hospital Mildred goes to
the kitchen to find Betsy holding her
Peach she demands it back but Betsy
taunts her by taking a bite instead
unfortunately for her that was Timothy
shalom's Peach although infuriated
Mildred remains composed and simply
warns that she will regret her actions
their dispute is suddenly interrupted by
Richard who admits that the earlier
labotomy weren't a success as he hoped
therefore he'll be demonstrating an
alternative operating procedure the
transorbital labotomy involving drilling
through the ey sock it oh to access the
thinnest part of the skull as the
procedure commences Richard inserts the
ice pick just above the eye and hammers
it to a certain depth this site disgusts
Betsy causing her to puke on the floor
Richard is furious to see this and kicks
her out of the operating room on the
contrary Mildred is fascinated by the
procedure and applauds for the doctor oh
very sexy doctor the next day she is
having her lunch in the kitchen when
she's approached by gwendelyn after a
brief chitchat and introduction sendin
offers to show Mildred around town which
the latter agrees to following this she
takes her to a bar where she teaches
Mildred how to eat oers you just got to
go gwendelyn then drives her to a
women's bar assuming Mildred to be a
lesbian like herself however this only
offends the latter promoting her to
storm out of the place in Anger
meanwhile at the hospital Richard brings
Edmund to his office for psychiatric
evaluation however the young man Rambles
on and on about antennas in his head and
other matters Richard suspects that he
is exaggerating his mental illness in
order to avoid the death penalty in an
attempt to fetch the truth he claims
that he doesn't believe in capital
punishment and that he wants to help him
despite his efforts Edmond doesn't
reveal anything so Richard calls his
security guard to take him back to his
cell in the next scene Mildred receives
a call from father Andrews who finally
agrees to share his story about the
massacre as a result she picks him up
and drives him to her motel room while
he's distracted she discreetly slips an
an aesthetic into his tea eventually
making him feel dizzy and pass out when
he regains his Consciousness Andrews
finds himself strapped to the bed at
this point in time Mildred reveals that
Edmund is none other than her brother
leaving him in utter shock she further
asserts that he wasn't born a monster
someone turned him into one following
this Revelation Mildred performs a
labotomy on Andreas driving an ice pick
into his eye in the final scene two
State prosecutors visit father Andrews
to question him about Edmond but he is
now completely mute and
paralyzed subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching